we have with us this afternoon professor
josé Casanova and as you heard me talk
he's one of great sociologies truly
great sociologist of religion today I
think that the text that you have
assigned for today is just about the
best thing available at all to read on
sociology of religion so it's a it's a
great great pleasure for us to have
professor Casanova with us again today
this is his second time participating in
faith and globalization of course and he
was asking me to make some comparative
judgment between this class and the
previous one and I told him that that I
told that I love all my children equally
and each is special in their own ways
but in honor of professor Casanova who I
had only realized that today has
actually seriously over extended period
of time studied theology and studied by
a student of one of the really truly
great 20th century Catholic theologians
Karl Rahner I've now tell you a story of
karl about Karl Rahner in honor of
professor Casanova but i hope to your to
your benefit when i was a student at
university of tubing and that there was
a lecture announced by the great
catholic theologian Karl Rahner and he
was to receive a major award there he
was at that time something like 85 years
of age he had influenced the the course
of the Catholic theology and Catholic
Church indeed because he was active were
the major events in Catholic Church in
the light in the in the 60s Second
Vatican Council the major theologian of
Second Vatican Council the kind of
intellectual giant true
if there was was one and the lecture
that was announced was it was plastered
all over this small university town of
tubingen and it read intellectually
adultes in zis eldest it was
intellectual patients in itself and so
we were all you know kind of looking
through this at the title and kind of
pondering what might the great great
theologian say about the very essence of
intellectual patients you know you're
just all puzzled about the title and
kind of didn't know what to what to make
of it and it stands up when he's
delivering this lecture and says you
know there was a slight mistake in
transmission of my title the title
should be the intellectually the
intellectually get dueled meters ich
selbst intellectual patients with one
self here he is 85 years of age one of
the greatest right and one of the last
public lectures that he gave was the
public public lecture on intellectual
patients with one self now around this
time of the course many a student has
lost intellectual patients with
themselves there's material it has kind
of a mast and it's going in every which
direction and new things are coming at
you from every every side I think maybe
it's a good time to remind oneself to
have intellectual patients with oneself
and that pieces that seem disjointed now
may fall in place in a particular way in
surprising way in the course of this
this this class also I think sometimes
when I talk to Divinity School students
I talked also about spiritual patients
with oneself because very often when one
studies religion or one's own cherished
convictions about faith get to be
unsettled then suddenly the frame that
you brought with you is all out of whack
and you think the whole world might be
possibly out of whack you don't know how
to orient yourself in the world anymore
again a certain patients with oneself
for the pieces to come back together for
more old paradigm to use them as pawns
language for all paradigm maybe to give
way to something something new and the
time in between of sifting and changing
that can be a painful but very creative
and very important time so now to
session number five fades as shapers of
globalization is you will call our last
session was about secularization and
transformation of faiths in encounter
with globalization processes the present
session is primarily about the impact
possible impact of faiths on
globalization processes and that's a
central session for us in many ways
because we are asking how these two
interact and whether there is any
possibility of the resources of faith
traditions being brought to bear upon
globalization processes just as we were
asking of the impact of globalization
processes upon faiths and presupposition
444 what we are doing here is that there
is this progressive globalization that
is combined with vibrancy of faiths and
so the question becomes is how does one
understand this single process of
globalization in conjunction with
multiplicity of different faiths and
also of different cultures and the
question is whether there is only one
way to globalize or they may be multiple
ways to globalize and when we talked
about secularization we talked about
then now in recent years a thesis that
was suggested by isenhart but also
professor Casanova is one of the main
main proponents as well as Charles
Taylor of multiple modernity's and you
have read a piece by
Taylor or multiple modalities which
provides in many ways a kind of
intellectual analysis of the processes
of modernization and how and the role
that cultural element plays in
globalization modernization processes
and roughly I think one can then
analogously say to the thesis of
multiple modernities that we have in my
term something like a globalization in
multiple cultural registers you can
recognize it as a single worldwide
process and yet it looks very
differently depending on where you find
yourself and those multiple cultural
settings they inflict if you want
globalization processes in the
particular way they shape those
globalization processes and I think that
element of cultural shaping of
globalization processes I think it's a
very significant element for this class
and we can debate what extent Taylor's
thesis stands what do we do with that
cultural element versus kind of our
cultural elements of globalization but I
did sportin for us to to to name that I
think it's significant also for us to
keep in mind how it is that Taylor
defines culture right and definition of
culture I mean that there many of the
definition the many definitions of
culture but he uses the culture to
describe the kind of the set of explicit
and tacit convictions about the self
about society about the good about the
nature as a whole about the world that's
he's for the purposes of that paper but
that's his definition of culture and
you'll recall how in the last part of
his essay he talks about this kind of
tacit unspoken dimension that's not
expressed necessarily in beliefs but
simply in kinds of expectations with
which one operates that's a very
important element which he uses in his
your mary called me talking about his
doors
per book the secular age where he's
interested in the conditions under which
now the question of God is a problematic
one rather than simply being self
understood one and talks about
secularization in these in these terms
that's also what he's trying to express
with this kind of range of tacit
convictions as well as believe he calls
it social imaginary right which makes
certain certain things natural for us to
do natural for us to quote unquote
natural for us to believe now for our
purposes here this whole idea of self
society nature and the good as key
elements of the culture are very
important is you will recall I have from
the very beginning maybe controversially
but defined religions or fades as being
precisely fundamentally in wide
varieties of ways about that they offer
overarching interpretation of reality
they situate the self in an overarching
interpretation of reality and they ask
the question what does it mean to live
well what is the account of the good
life and that good account of the good
life is connected with the idea of that
good so if it's the case that our
globalization refracts itself through
this way of understanding of culture as
Taylor suggests then obviously you can
say well how do the accounts of the
world of the self or social relations of
the good that are embedded in bodied in
faith traditions how do they interact
intersect with globalization processes
and indeed if we if you look then and
some of the religious thinkers that we
have had a sign for today you will see
that that's precisely the level at which
they're engaging globalization processes
they're engaging globalization processes
also at the kind of moral level but more
deeply I think they're engaging it at
this level of interpretation of reality
of the self and the
relations now I'll instead of commenting
here about benedict the sixteen and John
Paul the second in this particular text
that you've read I'm going to take what
we did last year which I think was a
better reading we made a mistake we read
Dalai Lama and we read a different piece
by John Paul the second and I want to
give you a bit of flavor of what they
have what they have said which will
basically confirm about benedict the
sixteen or the type of approach of
Benedict the sixteenth the reason for
been induced 16 stacks is that it's very
recent that's put kind of the the latest
that has come out from a major leader of
world communion on the question of
globalization but partly to give you a
flavor also of more religions because
Buddhism this time around isn't as
prominent as it was last year some other
religions are we're kind of migrating
from one iteration of this course to the
next in terms of religions but partly
also because it Illustrated so well I'll
invoke also dalai lama by the way the
same issue was present as i recall the
number of times issue of the good the
human flourishing the way of life in our
original session about bin Laden
argument was it was not simply either
irrational outburst of hatred against
something in the West but rather that it
is informed by a whole account of what
it means to live well in the context of
a religious interpretation of life
account which we many of us find
problematic but nonetheless that's what
it was let me now just mention I have
about three and a half minutes and i'll
try to mention very quickly john paul
the second and dalai lama just quick
summary of what day what day what i do
in the paper in the papers which we can
try to make available also for you but
generally their engagement with
globalization processes and this is a
direct address of that very issue
John Paul the second first affirmation
is about the self the self is human
person he says it's by nature endowed
with universal inviolable and in Alien
able rights kind of human self as a
bearer of rights it's a universal claim
it's also a faith claim it's endowed by
the creator obviously affirmation to he
makes concerned social relations and I'm
picking out key central informations
that he makes justice he says between
people of course is rooted in love love
or to define he argues fundamentally
relations between humans not
self-interest right obviously you have
to ought to hear it as not simply
self-interest right our also as a
critical comment love defines
fundamentally relations between humans
justice as equality and respect for
rights is essential part of love but
love includes something more than
justice right you had the same theme in
the Benedict's text of the Benedict or
Benedict way that we read and then comes
injunction which is kind of a moral
imperative that flows out of this you
have to have globalization globalization
is fine but it has to be without
marginalization of people and human
person must be the center of every
social project people should not engage
in only seeking their own good the
weakest must be supported and this
applies to people everywhere and
every-time and then finally he comes to
a motivation of the for the whole thing
motivation is the vision of the good in
Benedict's text it is this city of god
right or a little bit lower down it's
the common common good all right 44 John
Paul the second it's God the Creator who
by definition Islam why is it that human
beings ought to love one another because
at the very foundation of reality is the
one who is love that's the definition of
the good and all I call therefore to
share in Christ's Universal redemption
to say give themselves to others as
Christ has done himself quick run down
through dalai lama i have minus one
minute is that right ok ok I'll quick
run down to through Dalai Lama
affirmation one all desire happiness and
seek to avoid suffering it's in the
sense that's almost like a definition of
the good with which he operates
affirmation to about the self all have
equal rights to pursue those goals and
the formation three concerns the social
relations altruism and compassion of the
ultimate source of human happiness and
then affirmation for we simply follows
from this is altruism and compassion are
the medicine for all human nails key
whether to equitable use of natural
resources or resolution of conflicts now
i'm giving a very quick rundown down
these things i don't expect you to write
those necessarily down what I just want
you to keep in mind is that you see what
this but is to arguably of the greatest
leaders religious leaders of the second
half of the 20th century have done what
they have done is basically they've
taken the account of the good of the
self of social relations nature of
reality and they kind of brought it to
bear on social social relations in this
particular case on globalization
processes that kind of fits together
with Taylor's account that globalization
processes refract themselves through
culture understood as embodying
explicitly or tacitly in accounts of
self social relations and others by the
way humanism also is a particular
account of the self of nature of social
relations and also of the good right so
it's not simply religious prerogative to
hack those but rather that can be
non-religious accounts nonetheless that
seems to me to be a significant aspect
of how faiths
intersect with globalization processes
and with this i think i will end and see
the floor to my friend prevents array